só para superlotar está achando que
ninguém bateu palmas na verdade eu
estava demonstrando trabalho
quem está aqui vai tentar ter graça de
vez em quando lá estava um ano bom só
com diante mas não obedeceu vir aqui
falar do meu percurso em branco diante
vai ser diferente e eu faria o google e
procura merda que não se interessam
também falar de viagens que é uma coisa
que me interessa muito é uma grande
paixão
eu já fui a cerca de 40 e poucos países
e e achei que era mais dinheiro vir aqui
partilhar essas minhas experiências e
viaja comigo você viajar é 36 anos
quando os meus avós e os tios avós não
valem logo a londres
portanto seis anos de muito carinho e
depois a partir daí começaram a voar a
mach fui por israel e nova york foi
sondada minha mãe e os meus primos
isto é extremamente enriquecedor só seja
foi em paz onde vão ser é muito
importante acho o valor das crianças
viajavam nós quando chegamos temos
alguns investimos num esforço da
educação estava que o eduardo sabe quem
fala assim não ajudam as crianças seguem
ganhando seu entretanto vai rolar quando
eu vi já foi popular
o intercâmbio foi duas semanas papel de
que vá morar com gente do tony do chipre
e da holanda da manhã e histérico quilo
aquela relação toda estará livre somente
coisas miúdas de altônia pr foi esperto
e clara e se tiver que volta é lisboa
foi para focolares que vem logo em
erasmus fizera josé república checa é e
mais tarde a trabalhar esteja em nenhum
lugar e teve muita história para contar
sobre isso pois não há tempo para tudo
né
como se vê já agora como viajar
há muitas maneiras de muitas formas de
viajar e todas elas são legítimas
a não ser que seja um correio de droga
vítima hawks com bolotas de haxixe do
cupra vez não é legal não pode fazer
isso não seria mas também as outras
formas de viajar são os itens há quem
prefira e duas semanas da república
dominicana pulseira no pulso estar a
limpar a porta os mandantes só achei
interessante a 0
esse é um item há quem vá a londres que
significa o inverno vai comer - a loja
de manhã ouves tanto valor
sai joão paulo ii tá tudo bem pois ao
extremo de viagem já só satisfaça virá
todo no pan amazônia equipado com os
quadros um apenas para fazer o quê pra
galera cada um escolhe sua maneira de
jogar e como é que se sente bem em
viajar mas provavelmente não é assim tão
e rexona estiverem só duas semanas e
chegou à frente à loja de miami 12 mundo
né
como é que faz para viajar tanto seu
produto em fazer muito
como é que faz para viajar viajar tanto
quem vê né
pa isso é estúpido perdida até porque
vem muitas vezes se de documentários
como a deve estar querendo ele não é seu
sol s
quem está com dengue também não tinhas
já que não tem graça e sempre mantém não
tinha esses também não não vai faltar à
audiência e não tinha
depois eu acho engraçado este
comentários por normalmente são
comentários que fazem no instagram
através do seu telemóvel costume mil
euros
o pessoas que vão comprar um carro novo
ou pessoas cujo ideal de férias de duas
semanas no apartamento supervalorizado
em vilamoura por exemplo de sucesso dos
outros e tentar sem graça que era uma
coisa fina não é estúpido estúpido mil
euros gastei o paciente semanas da índia
incluindo o vôo
tanto uma questão eu trazer as peças
pessoas
é legítimo que discordam das férias em
vilamoura um carro novo não sei que
planta é uma questão de carregar nada
sobre isso é uma questão de prioridades
são prioridade assim e não se arrepende
aqui os usuários a mais
é uma questão privada assim que é o que
eu mais gosto em viaja há outras coisas
que eu gosto acho que há coisas que são
normais práticas são comuns a toda a
gente que é comida é o momento de
conhecer pessoas
depois há uma coisa que gosto mesmo há
duas coisas que não são propriamente
tangíveis em fado está tanto viaja uma
delas é ex línguas negras pessoas falam
e pensam eu adoro adoro estar num país
seja a china índia bulgária onde eu não
perceber nada do controle será volta
nada pra mim é uma forma diferente
silêncio e muitas vezes é uma forma de
financiar mais bonita do que o silêncio
propriamente dito
osg isto para tirar fotos com o ator
esclarece a frase incrível que me dizer
nada quero dizer pra isto leva a uma
parte mais pequena é visto esta questão
de sentir este silêncio em frente por
não perceber nada como idéia é bem isso
que a coisa que eu mais gosto de viajar
é sempre desconfortável é incerteza do
que vai acontecer
a aventura adrenalina sempre em frente
pela rua em frente dando do meu dia a
dia tanto com este conforto como causa o
maior prazer em viajar e que faz com que
veja cada vez mais
ora para onde onde tem um cadáver que o
pulsar em londres e não sei que difere
muito de pessoa para pessoa
as pessoas podem querer ir para a
amazônia podem crer e para as cidades
podem crer e cimentaram querem tudo a
mesma coisa que faço e para destinos
mais exóticos é este desconforto e por
exemplo não ter a mão sempre uns estar
wax wifi rua e propósito disto é destino
exótico contratar um pequeno história
como aconteceu na índia
fui para a índia e sozinho
cinco semanas e tava aquela velha ndash
passado 30 horas de viagem de quase 40
horas com escalas fôrma ermírio torto
umas horas no aeroporto baa epa tava de
haxixe cheguei sabia que campanha um
metro mais ou menos no cap confuso
fui com as que perceber que não queria
apanhar um táxi equipe da merda
princípio tal meta no metro sentou se ao
lado de fato impecável
estamos a falar ele trabalhava no
departamento de marketing uma cerveja
qualquer indiana e sim israel disse um
deles onde crianças vão fazer comigo não
sei que saímos dela é um calço um caos
próximo
só quem foi lá e consegui perceber que a
poluição sonora e visual é o objetivo é
que não cause mais de 40 horas mal
dormidas e hoje tudo lixado a vida tudo
bem para mim e eu falo com oncinha do
tuc tuc programa leva a que os rapazes
aquela que é nossa naquela zona oeste
outro qualquer e eu voto com pedro do
tuco mesmo sanar como sanar começamos a
andar e até três lugares de que mostre
muito espécie mas nossa voz não pôs
turismo eo dólar e plantaram da equipe
entre os turismos hoje ele coloque o tuk
tuks achou não é que a amazônia está
quebrada e os 160 e não quis entrar
explicou que as executam 160 não quer
sentar e explicar o fim do túnel é assim
vai o centro francês em time está com
solado é que vais é que vai até ganhou
um número qualquer do hotel voltou a
faltar fechado porque vai ser o novo
indiana onde o audi vai ser humano
precisa está fechado e não sei que não
dá para falar agora mas se quiser o
resto já que o comboio padre que a
cidade está mal e não quer ficar aqui no
dela não sei que há mas também por
padres possa arranjar um hotel é que no
centro da cidade por 500 dólares à noite
o que não quero é obrigado a arrancar e
vou te boto já ficar bocado chateado com
isso
policiais não se viu nada não sei que é
possível qualquer vamos encontrar
encontrar o o assunto e vai até falar um
inglês macarrônico às tantas o tutu que
falou assim qualquer merda e eu nem
gosta de bronx brooklyn bronx
a gazzetta blogs e eu ficar cada vez
mais não vou colocar esse tema é como
estar na sede do estado realmente já não
tava achar graça nenhuma
e prepara-se o tutuca e este faz um
papagaio também toma silva de 30 anos
assim chega o outro é e aí sim o que ele
quer mesmo é muito mais simpático mas
não falou em um inglês muito melhor
vamos como eu vou com ela começa a falar
te tão antecipado e chegamos a uma zona
contar uma estrada bloqueada com o
senhor qualquer não desiste de polícia
a east of his de bateria da escola de
escolas bom eu ficar nervoso nervoso
passar por mesa e eu vai para no posto 3
mil não já sei quem vou dizer não querer
que não age por 36 ser expulso de 6 ser
e eu vou posture gendre cento e não quer
sentar cento não quer sentar eu cedo
explicou liga o centro ao escolas escola
aí o que era algo que nos fazem a ai
caraças jogou ficar completamente
nervoso com aquilo e eu disse olha mas
restam até o que não quero já sai não
quer sair lá os véus medo em nova déli
sozinho se esperava
vou por esse novo de outubro ea segunda
vai enganar também vai arranjar a equipe
não se de qualquer com lojas com
qualquer merda mesmo se vê até que
chegamos a uma praça gigante nova vela
eu sai do que acontece em conta os
avantes lima neto peço o bari chegou a
soprano e isso é tudo verdade é dura
mas exigirá e vamos foto ser mundo ea
internet pois posso dizer que foi a
viagem da minha vida foi um sonho fique
potro top ninguém e nem acreditava para
frente à com quem tem portanto também já
viajei várias maneiras em grupo só como
absurdamente minha amiga sozinho
enquanto as com alguém é meio a um grupo
sujeito agir por tantas coisas para
partilhar está sujeito a não convém
escolherem bem com quem vão viajar pra
não sei não sei que ela me parece uma
velha que não pode andar dez minutos já
está que já não pode terminar o assunto
não tenha sorte sim que não possa comer
uma taxa como hóspede na maioria das
vezes até é dos melhores sítios com vai
escolher mas agora viaja sozinha em
incrível é incrível e recomenda a toda a
gente e foi de que minha inspiração para
não cair nunca porque é uma coisa que
surgiu em cada luta ânsia em viajar
sozinhos podem não sabe por isso a
passear
depois que na viagem os melhores times
muito sozinhos mas tem coisas marcha
solidão acontece por contestar
missivistas sozinho pois às vezes é
chato que nós temos que nos aturar nós
próprios
durante cinco semanas até sempre nós nós
e nós sim e ainda por cima se forem eu
era chato muita coisa estúpida fechado
torna se cansativo mas foi muito
enriquecedor e gostei de toda a gente a
uma vez na vida é viajar sozinho por
fazendas viagem é que eu quero falar
mais do que não fazer e como fazer é
fácil cada um escolhe a sua credora e
ele então as minhas histórias suicídios
outros e psiu arquitetura outros querem
preparar e está tudo bem
rafa dar exemplo de não serem atrasados
mentais a viajar
vamos parar com isso por exemplo foram
foi de salvar pessoas em cima pra
enfrentados tempo todo uma árvore depois
dos 30 selada uma saída de fotos stubb
para com isto este igualmente tigres
acorrentados e isso já não estava nem
tirar fotos com antigos drogados e é
subir nos parar com isto e o mesmo
espaço aqui pra quem vem a portugal
vamos parar com isto é subir na
argentina é bárbara twitter vargas
tanques enquanto turistas que falam
disto não quer entrar muito no tema das
touradas quem conhece a floresta merda
mas anuncia também por turistas no
algarve a bufar buffay absurdo de onda
agora é clichês
é só passar o verão que gosto também de
viagem com gol mas quando você viaja não
tirar fotos e gir mostrados em meio ou
em segredo não só evitar algumas frases
estava cheia nós fôssemos foi de ficar
na mesmice tim ries investir pés não é
tão profundo cesumar ver um carro também
foi positivo ter leis estúpidas e já é
alguma coisa com a qual estamos nele
ficamos mais ricos estavam encostados
antes giro giro constatar houve
consentimento
e depois isso é muito grave que fazem é
como a infância mas essas fotos não é
ela e rolls do titanic aqui eu não sei
isso foi assinado por mim no sri lanka
que estava sendo esta rocha
olha a pastora não sei que estou fazendo
aqui um monte de pessoas pois esta é que
o pai ela fazia assim só irá amá la e
tirar fotos
aproveitar trágico ver pelo menos fazem
faltas
vamos evitar ser atrasados mentais a
viajar por amor de deus é que não estão
no museu da escravatura e não se você é
jovem e escravatura não é fish não se
sabe é se quem escreva tudo gol site é
triste o rival português foram
espetaculares nisso
não não é para fazer um limbo elenco é
que não é uma escravatura
5º inc não é suposto que fez foi trazer
isto nem isto é um memorial aos judeus
mortos na europa e yoga fim sem perder e
câmeras de gás fundo não isso é super
errado acho que aí tem as coisas pensam
que não resultam em forma em são paulo
mas vamos ver isso faz tudo em um carro
ao xix e desde então ninguém eu já tenho
em auschwitz vocês já tiveram em cível
estar feliz lá em incêndios no ar é
miséria que a humanidade sente essa
merda que é que o game apresenta é
horrível é possível que ele fique e eu
tiro o elenco é que o paulo travou saúde
estou aqui ou 10 milhões de pessoas o
espetáculo não parem com isso favor e
pra cá agora ela está diferente
perguntou muito quando vai pessoalmente
da viagem grande na índia agora será que
é tão difícil assim uma data semanas
esta pessoa diferente é pai não do psb
do rio
assim vinícius ottoni frente contra meu
eu interior
é a vida embora enfrente vesti frente
porque precisa dizer o que andré pobreza
para finalmente dá jogo de volta em casa
está errado como você curte já a partida
não é não precisas já vir dar valor ao
que tais níveis de paz graças a deus não
sou diferente
a clin mesmo que por que ser diferente e
mudar um carro afundar um cara e
apreenderam um carro
ora isto não aprende eu tenho todos
aprenderam um caso muito mais suave já
seja londres seja braga seja o que
forçou viajar no dia a dia e tenta
prender um capuz todos os dias tento ser
um caminho diferente
aprendemos com que nem todo dia estamos
a fazer o que tanto esse clichê sou rico
do planeta que tivemos hoje foi obrigado
a quem quiser pode passar nesse grande
por peixe tem que ser realmente dia até
nem é esse tag sensivelmente idiota em
cuba é extremamente atuante lanka
envolver demais fotos e muito mais
histórias que eu vou escrevendo nas
fotos de viagens
caso contrário não gostarem tem essa
falta ver também que para já não está
grande e vão lá e faça um maquinista
foto que é uma honra incrível sobre a
matar
[Aplausos]